احدث اتسمت بحساسيه كبيره تطرق اليها
مسلسل ذكراون وضعته في مرمى الانتقادات
خاصه في موسمه الخامس رئيس وزراء بريطانيا
الاسبق جون نيجر شانه هجوما شديدا حول
مشهد الملك تشارلز الذي كان امير ولز
انذاك وهو يقطع عطلته مع زوجته ديانا
لاستضافه اجتماع السري معه عام
1991 لمناقشه الاطاحه بالملكه اليزابيث
الثانيه عن العرش مجر كتب رساله قائلا
المسلسل مؤلم للغايه لعائله لا تزال حزينه
على الشخص الذي بنيت الدراما باكملها على
حياتها ايضا يظهر المسلسل تشارلز ويؤدي
دوره دومين كويس اثناء محاوله تجميد رئيس
الوزراء الاسبق طوني بلير كحاليف لحمايه
مستقبله وتمهيد الطريق للزواج من كامله
بعد فتره وجيزه من الانتخابات العامه
1997 ردا على هذا المشهد قال المتحدث باسم
بلير هذا هوراء كامل ونتفليكس لا تحترم
ذكرى اولئك الذين لم يعودوا على قيد
الحياه اما الممثله جودي دانيتش التي ادت
دوره الملكه فيكتوريا في المسلسل
فانتقدته هي الاخرى واصفه اياه بظالم
بقسوه للعائله الملكه